rappelez vous c'était le 2 octobre
dernier les policiers manifestaient leur
mécontentement dans les rues de fort de
france
depuis plusieurs mois voire même des
années ils alertent sur le manque de
moyens matériels et humains ainsi que la
montée d'une violence de plus en plus
présente
autant de problématiques qui font fumée
la cocotte minute au début du mois de
septembre les syndicats rencontrera les
élus locaux
toujours dans ce même contexte quelques
jours plus tard citoyens et policiers se
mobiliser ensemble des interpellations
publiques qui auront visiblement
occasionné la visite du directeur
général de la police nationale éric
morvan de passage en martinique lundi et
mardi derniers il a rencontré les
syndicats de police pour faire le point
sur leur situation
un directeur général il est là pour
mettre en application aussi les
directives du politique
donc on ne s'attend pas à des miracles
nous sommes actuellement à 57 tentatives
d'homicides 19 homicides
quand vous additionnez les deux qu'un
potentiellement 76 donc homicide
nous lui avons demandé si compte tenu de
ces chiffres là si compte tenu du fait
que nous soyons départements français
d'accord européen mais non territoire
schengen avec tout ce que cela comporte
comme contrôles aux frontières et tout
s'il y avait d'autres départements
français de l'hexagone qui étaient dans
cette situation là alors ce sur quoi les
110 ko avant tout me l'action c'est de
prendre en compte la réalité du terrain
et les spécificités de l'île
celui ci a nous a répondu qu'il aurait
un regard tout particulièrement
attentifs si dans les conditions dans
lesquelles nous devrons et qui
tenteraient de répondre
de manière temporaire par globalement à
aux problématiques à savoir
qu'effectivement nous aurons un
renforcement des effectifs en principe
de la compagnie départementale
d'intervention des effectifs de nos
services également des changements
annoncés mais pas encore planifié et si
les moyens humains sont évoqués les
moyens matériels ne serait pas pour le
moment la priorité
pourtant martinique environ 25 % du parc
automobile de la police ne serait pas
fonctionnel réduisant alors le nombre de
patrouilles